sourire en coin
saïd mohammad est le dernier candidat à
s'être présenté devant la presse samedi
dernier les journalistes nombreux et
curieux à l'idée de savoir si cet ancien
membre des gardiens de la révolution
iranienne a la carrure pour devenir le
prochain président de la république
islamique
nous ne sommes liés à aucun mouvement
parti ou factions et nous ne nous sommes
assis avec personne et n'avons rien
promis notre gouvernement sera un
gouvernement de méritocratie sarlat les
arabes l'ex général d'y être porté par
les demandes du guide suprême iranien
l'ayatollah ali khamenei
ce dernier souhaitant une transformation
de la génération dirigeante vieillissant
celle qui a participé à la fameuse
révolution de 1979 et oeuvrer à la
naissance de la république islamique en
iran toutes les candidatures sont
examinées puis validé par le conseil des
gardiens de la constitution nous sommes
aussi en train de passer un cap
générationnel de notre point de vue
l'entrée des jeunes dans le champ
politique est important aussi et
peut-être la promesse de voir nos jeunes
entrés sur le terrain politique et jouer
un rôle à des niveaux élevés du pouvoir
exécutif
aujourd'hui plus d'une vingtaine de
personnalités publiques ont annoncé
officiellement leur candidature pour
briguer un mandat de quatre ans avec
l'ombre de l'armée qui plane plus que
jamais sur ces élections
outre said mohammad l'amiral rostam
ghasemi ancien ministre du pétrole a
aussi présenté son programme
présidentiel a ajouté le général hossein
d'art kahn ancien ministre de la défense
ou encore ezatollah zarghami ex membre
des gardiens de la révolution
une omniprésence militaire pointé du
doigt en coulisses par l'actuel ministre
iranien des affaires étrangères
critiqué par les conservateurs est
plongé dans une affaire d'état mohammad
javad zarif a présenté ses excuses sur
les réseaux sociaux
dans la foulée le guide suprême iranien
a préféré recentrer les débats à
l'abattage base s masse udine quechua g
et de veau d'or
bien sûr on a entendu quelque chose de
la part de certains responsables du pays
qui fait qu'on s'interroge et qu'on
regrette à moi et à aso
nous avons entendu que les médias de
l'ennemi qui sont contre la république
islamique
les ont également diffusé m'ont relevé
on regrette quand on entend ces mots
certains de ces mots sur la répétition
des mots au style de nos ennemis
la répétition des mots des états unis
l'ordre est affreux crassement n'ayez
touchera l'ensemble la menace venant de
l'occident au centre également des
élections présidentielles et diplomates
mais le plus souvent ferme chaque
candidat s'est exprimé au sujet de
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien dont
les pourparlers reprennent vendredi